please welcome Academy board member from
our writers branch Academy Award nominee
and the chair of the nickel fellowship
committee Robin swipe court well you
don't get to be the chair of the nickel
committee without being a governor so I
am clinging to my position on the board
it's just so that I can be ahead of this
committee I love the work that we do and
I love the people who come to be part of
the committee this year we had over
7,000 applications for this fellowship
so you might ask how do you arrive at
choosing five finalists out of that you
just download 7,000 scripts to your
Kindle no I actually I put them on my
phone because then when I'm in traffic I
could just kind of scroll through that
no no the the organizational heavy
lifting gets done by two Academy staff
members Greg Beale and Gen Y and they
really do need another round of applause
they wrangle a small army of
professional readers who evaluate the
tsunami of scripts that come in the
readers have to follow specific
guidelines for evaluation that are
supplied by our committee we came up
with them we refined them we've put them
into practice and so far it feels like
it's working these professional readers
are the ones who winnow through the big
pile of material and to make them took a
smaller pile and at that point 300-400
quarterfinalist scripts get read again
and they've been read multiple times
before this moment I won't bore you with
that but we end up giving that 300 or
400 over to the Academy members
themselves who then read multiple
scripts get read again multiple times
and we ask them to follow the same
guidelines that we've given the readers
and I'll give you a sense of what they
are we tell them to look for realz
tellers stories that have an original
premise that make the reader feel as
though we're being taken or taken on a
journey we say find the stories that
make the reader connect emotionally to
the protagonists bring us writers who
know how to tell a story with a strong
beginning middle and end and if not then
at least two out of the three are the
characters vivid does the dialogue seem
to fly directly off the page in real
real human speech and I dialogue that
sounds like real real dialogue except a
little bit better
does the doesn't writer have consistent
control over the tone of the script we
asked the readers to look for writers
who have distinctive voices who bring
something fresh to the page we asked
does reading the script make you think
this person genuinely has the potential
to develop into a real writer we're not
looking for the finished product we're
looking for that person who's going to
have a future because they're beginning
is so good and we also ask is the script
about something powerful because the
best movies the movies that endure
always seem to carry important universal
themes and it's not only dramas but
comedies - as we saw this summer with
the comedy the big sick movies that are
about something stay with us and one of
the most important things we ask our
readers of the core is something that we
call on this committee magic that
indescribable something that elevates
the scripted is something far above the
ordinary something that makes the script
unforgettable so you'll notice that
nowhere in our guidelines do we say
bring us a movie that we would like to
greenlight tomorrow nowhere do we say
bring us perfect screenplays that's
because we're not looking for projects
we're looking for writers who have voice
who are original thinkers who have some
mastery of the craft as filmmakers but
birth perhaps not quite yet all and who
have something valuable to say in their
own unique way
and by the time this committee convenes
upstairs on the seventh floor we are
looking at anywhere from twelve to ten
finalists and in the years since we
adopted these guidelines things have
just gotten better and better but that
also means that these meetings have
become impossible because all we do is
have these impassioned ranting arguments
with each other which go on for hours we
really only cater one meal so it limits
how long we can stay in there we change
our votes we convince each other with
something and then change our minds
again we argue back and forth about
scripts number five and six a lot but
usually we do finally all come to a
common agreement on the top five but
always always with really strong regret
that we only have the capacity to grant
five fellowships because the honest
truth is we could grant ten every script
is so deserving this year I'll tell you
where we landed we really landed on
scripts that we felt spoke to the time
that we're living in that the writers
who had given us these scripts really
had something on their minds subjects
and themes that reached us deeply
Kristin Rock maker looks at morality and
whether wrongdoing makes a person evil
when that wrong is done in the service
of something good Sarah Jane and words
posed a future world when aliens
arriving into small-town American life
are treated with a range of tolerance
and intolerance as the Bosnians and
Somalian refugees that Sarah knew as a
child in Minnesota retreated say Sarah
Vitale explored the impact of oncoming
mortality on a man who has never yet
been his best self is it is there still
time to change and Max lancengi and
Bailey collaborated on a story about a
woman striving for her success and
survival in a profession that his
handicapped her because she is female
and who finds herself making costly
compromises of the soul that diminished
her and the rest of us as she struggles
to make her mark
vigil team a brings us a story from
Nigeria that feels like it is pulled
from the headlines of today's paper
about schoolgirls kidnapped my militants
who resourcefully managed to escape even
as the father of one of the girls comes
looking for his daughter these are
stories from our time and for our time
by five writers who I believe will shape
the films that we will watch in the
future for decades to come so tonight
the Academy and the nickel committee
honors these five writers and encourages
their future work by awarding each of
them a nickel fellowship for 2017
[Applause]
[Music]